Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wir machen einen Podcast. Also Salon. Heute ist Salon.
Heute ist Salon. Wir sprechen über das Buch Angststillstand,
warum die Meinungsfreiheit schwindet von Richard David Precht.
Das ist ja ein Thema, das uns jetzt schon seit Monaten verfolgt in diesem Podcast.
Ist das Tier da vorne drauf?
Ja, was ist das für ein Tier? Das ist ein Axolotl und das hat selbstredend was mit dem Buch zu tun.
Ist aber noch keine Larve. Es gibt ja verschiedene Tierstadien.
Die uns gleich vorgestellt werden. Ja, ein Axolotl. Ja, genau.
Aber wir sind so eine Axolotl-Gesellschaft offenbar.
Wir schauen uns an, was das bedeuten kann.
Also ich bin kein Axolotl, Richard. Okay, warte.
Aber du bist ja nicht so unzufrieden mit dem Buch an sich, oder?
Also, das Buch kommt sehr nah ran an die Sachen, die mich interessieren.
Ja.
Hegemon. Wer ist Herr Hegemon? Wer bestimmt hier, wer sich für was wo rechtfertigen muss und so weiter.
Und ich möchte es ihm nicht verübeln, dass er natürlich über die Stränge schlägt.
Wir sind weder eine Generation noch ein Milieu ökonomischer Natur und deswegen
sieht er naturgemäß Sachen anders.
Aber noch eine Unterscheidung, ich bin Ossi, er ist Wessi.
Der Ausspruch, uns fragt ja keiner, den kenne ich von vor 20 Jahren aus dem Osten.
Ich habe vor einer Weile, einigen Jahren überlegt, ob ich vielleicht der Alten
Republik ein ostdeutsches Kapitel gebe.
Mit dem Hinweis, schaut es euch an, da seid ihr in 10 Jahren. Hier sind wir.
Ja, ganz interessant.
Also so ein paar Sachen begegnen mir wieder, wo ich mir denke,
ah ja, ist das jetzt eine westdeutsche Haltung, okay.
Ja, da bin ich sehr gespannt drauf. Was mich vor allem interessiert ist,
dass er sich zum einen mit rechtlichen Fragen auseinandersetzt,
dass er sagt, da hat sich gar nicht so viel verändert, dass er sich aber mit
der subjektiven Meinungsfreiheit befasst.
Da stellt sich ja die Frage, wie kann es sein, dass so viele Menschen inzwischen
sagen, dass sie sich nicht mehr frei fühlen, ihre Meinung zu äußern?
Woher kommt das? Denn das ist ja erstmal was, was dann Umfragen hergeben und
man muss sich fragen, wer ist dafür verantwortlich?
Kann man überhaupt einzelne Akteure dafür verantwortlich machen?
Was ist das für ein gesellschaftliches Klima,
in dem man eigentlich sagen muss, rechtlich hat sich nicht viel verändert,
bis auf so ein paar Dinge bezüglich Politikerbeleidigungen und so etwas,
das schauen wir uns dann auch genauer an, aber dass man trotzdem sagt,
hier hat sich radikal etwas verändert,
nämlich dass die Meinungsfreiheit ganz stark abgenommen hat,
wird subjektiv empfunden,
dass da Zahlen genannt werden, die wirklich erschütternd sind.
Und da nachzugehen, finde ich hochinteressant und es ist, glaube ich,
eine sehr gute Debattengrundlage, denn das Buch, ja, übertreibt mitunter,
aber es ist nicht eine Polemik.
Es ist nicht eines dieser Bücher, jetzt wird aber hier mal aufgeräumt und sonst
was, sondern es ist tatsächlich eine sehr klar argumentierte Hinführung.
Ja, wir können ja schon mal eine Frage voranstellen. Für alle,
die... Also das Buch hat ja noch keiner gelesen, es kommt ja heute erst raus.
Und man kann sich ja die Frage stellen, was ist eigentlich das treibende Problem
gerade? Und welches greift Richard David Precht auf?
Entweder dem Titel nach Angststillstand,
Also Leute zucken zurück, halten sich die Hand vor den Mund und denken,
das darf ich hier nicht sagen.
Oder aber alle, ohne weiter drüber nachzudenken, hauen nur noch ihr Zeug ins
Internet raus, wie kleine Kinder plappern sie drauf los.
Und erstaunlicherweise steht in diesem Buch beides als Problem drin.
Ja, das ist das. Und das wollen wir gleich mal auflösen. Ich bin sehr gespannt.
Das ist nämlich sehr streitbar, diese Frage, die ich jetzt gerade,
also diese Unterscheidung aufzulösen.
Ich kriege es auch noch nicht ganz zusammen, denn es gibt beide Phänomene und
das ist wirklich bemerkenswert.
Aber bevor wir dazu kommen, ist es ja so, dass zur Meinungsfreiheit auch gehört,
dass man sich kritisch äußert über kulturelle Erzeugnisse.
Hin und wieder tun wir das ja hier im Salon besonders.
Jetzt muss ich dich selbstredend fragen, wie gefällt dir das neue Album von Taylor Swift?
Ich habe das Cover gesehen, wo sie in der Badewanne liegt.
Oh Gott, was kommt jetzt für eine Antwort, Stefan?
Und dachte mir, super Fotoidee.
Ja.
Im Sinne von oben, unten, sichtbar, unsichtbar, aber es ist ja Wasser,
aber man sieht so eine Wasserkante. Also es war irgendwie ein interessantes Foto.
Olli, unser Fotograf hier in Frankfurt, hat mir gestern ein Bild von Heidi Klum
in Strumpfhose am Hauptbahnhof gezeigt und ich möchte hier eine Petition starten,
wenn schon Fotos dort, dann lieber...
So wie Taylor Swift.
Ja.
Und nicht wie Heidi Klum. Also es gibt ästhetische Unterschiede, möchte ich sagen.
Ansonsten, ich weiß es nicht. Ich habe gesehen, dass du hast Clips dazu mitgebracht.
Ich bin jetzt sehr gespannt. Ich habe noch nicht reingehört.
Ach so.
Ja.
Gut. Mir geht es jetzt gar nicht darum.
Die Musik... Hast du schon reingehört?
Ich habe mal reingehört, ja. Denn es gab den Streit darüber,
ob diese Songs anderen berühmten oder nicht so berühmten Songs gleichen.
Ob sie etwas kopiert hat. Ich kann das nicht beurteilen. Ich habe jetzt nicht
so tief reingehört und kann das auch nicht in der Weise miteinander vergleichen,
dass ich sage, ja genau, hier kann man es exakt sehen.
Es gibt Ähnlichkeiten, die sind mir so beim Hören, es wurde bei Spiegel Online,
wurden ja verschiedene Lieder so gegenübergestellt, dann in einem Ähnlichkeiten auch.
Spiegel Online hat eine Liedervergleichsanalyse gemacht.
Ja, allerdings ist es ja so, dass diese...
Man verzeihe mir diese Formulierung, sehr generisch produzierte Popmusik durchaus
sich immer mehr angleicht.
Generisch produziert ist noch besser als generiert.
Wodurch solche Ähnlichkeiten sich viel stärker ergeben.
Das ist, glaube ich, schon ein generelles Problem. Ich glaube,
es ist falsch, jetzt so zu tun, als sei Taylor Swift diejenige,
die die anderen Leute beraubt, um sich das anzueignen, um Hitze rauszumachen.
Sondern ich glaube, dass wir eine große Angleichung in der Popmusik erleben.
Was man auch daran sieht, dass man oft die Lieder, wenn man nicht großer Fan
ist und das alles hundertmal durchgehört hat, dass man sie kaum noch voneinander
unterscheiden kann, von welchen Künstlern sind sie gerade.
Und da ist meine bescheidene Popmusikerfahrung oder mein Wissen über die Popmusik
jetzt zum Beispiel auch der 80er oder der 70er Jahre eine andere,
da weiß man sehr genau, dass hier jetzt gerade dieses Lied von Tina Turner ist
und das ist das Lied von Cher und das würde man nicht mal zufällig vertauschen.
Ich will das nur sagen, dass sich hier eine große Angleichung ergeben hat und woher die kommt,
wissen wir ja, denn wir haben ja dieses wunderbare Buch von Liz Pelley besprochen
über Spotify und das ist ein wichtiger Grund für diese Angleichung, die stattfindet.
Und womit ich jetzt nicht sagen will, Taylor Swift ist einfach nur der Spotify-Algorithmus.
Sie hat sicherlich Talent und all das. Das ist ohnehin nicht meine Musik,
deswegen will ich mich da gar nicht tiefer mit beschäftigen.
Ich glaube nur diese Debatten, die es da jetzt gerade gibt, müssten viel grundsätzlicher
geführt werden. Jetzt ist es aber so, dass wohl einige Taylor Swift-Fans wiederum
enttäuscht sind von diesem neuen Album.
Jedenfalls jubeln sie es nicht so in den Himmel, wie sie das mit vorherigen Alben getan haben.
Was jetzt mir aufgefallen ist in den sozialen Medien ist, dass andere Influencer,
Creator sich dazu äußern, dass es Kritik an dem Album gibt und die,
Mitunter ist es ja notwendig, auch die Kritik zu kritisieren.
Aber ich glaube, man muss es ein bisschen intelligenter machen,
als zum Beispiel hier diese Variante Raffi redet.
Also dieses neue Taylor Swift-Album, ich finde es gar nicht mal so gut.
Ich finde es sehr gewöhnlich, super langweilig und die Lieder sind uns auch
nicht wirklich mal so gut.
Sag mal, geht's noch? Das ist eins der coolsten Alben, die sie je rausgebracht hat.
Schreib du erstmal während der Welttournee, die zwei Jahre lang geht,
wo du, keine Ahnung, 150 Auftritte hast, zu je dreieinhalb Stunden Live-Gesang, Performance und Tanz.
Schreib da mal ein Album. Aber nee, nee, nee, ohne Songwriter.
Das macht sie nämlich alles selber.
Sie schreibt die Texte selber, sie komponiert selber, sie macht alles selber.
Die Ideen fürs Musikvideo kommt alles von ihr.
Also mach du kleiner Pimmel ihr das erstmal nach und sei damit mal halb so erfolgreich.
Dann können wir nochmal reden, okay?
Ja, das ist natürlich Unsinn. Wir kennen das immer bei den Filmkritikern.
Da wird dann auch immer gesagt, ja, dreh du erstmal einen Film.
Ich habe noch nie eine Kamera in der Hand gehabt, weiß ich nicht,
wie das geht. Ich weiß aber, wie ein guter Film aussieht.
Ich will uns zurückschwenken auf eine Argumentation, die ich jetzt vorschlage.
Ich war die vergangene Woche in Lissabon und habe dort meine Kirchen rundtour gemacht.
Wahnsinnig tolle Bauwerke, 15. Jahrhundert.
Man ist ganz plötzlich Seefahrernation geworden, superreich und dann drei Generationen
später war schon wieder alles vorbei. Und diese Zeit wurde ausführlich genutzt.
Es gibt dort ein sehr großes Kloster, Santa Vincenzo, Pipapo de Faro oder so.
Da hängen die Patriarchen in der Galerie, also da kann man sich typischerweise
so wie im Kaisersaal hier nochmal die großen Köpfe der Stadt anschauen,
die natürlich alle auf Anfrage und mit Gnade des Papstes und so weiter die Geschäfte führten.
Das heißt, für die hat man ein Gebäude gebaut, von denen wir ja schon gelernt
haben, die sind eigentlich für den Klang hergestellt worden,
also große Kirchen vor allem.
In diesem Kloster gibt es also eine sehr große Kirche und ich war zweimal da
und beim zweiten Mal wurde durch Zufall Orgel gespielt.
Ich habe also diese Kirche so wahrgenommen, wie sie eigentlich gedacht war.
Ja, sie sieht auch schön aus und so, aber sie klingt vor allem wahnsinnig toll.
Und in dem Moment habe ich so gedacht, krass, du bist am Rande Europas.
Und im Grunde gibt es diese Kirchen, die kleinen Kirchen, hauptsächlich,
weil die Leute einfach, wir fahren morgen auf See, auf See sind wir in Gottes
Hand, vielleicht kommen wir zurück, vielleicht nicht, wir gehen vorher nochmal beten oder so.
Also man ist trotz Superreichtum, ist die Bevölkerung, ist jeder einfach komplett
im Schicksal. Man weiß einfach gar nicht, wie geht es hier weiter.
So, und dann gibt es für die wenigen, die so ein paar kleine Honorationen oder
sonstiges haben, die Möglichkeit, in so einer Kirche Orgelmusik zu hören.
Und der Unterschied vom 15. Jahrhundert zu heute ist, die AirPods Pro 3 von
Apple stellen ja den Ton im Grunde so dar, wie das wirklich in der Kirche klingt.
Das heißt, wir haben eine extreme Entgrenzung. Jeder darf diese Musik,
die ihm gefällt, überall hören.
Und ich finde, jede auch nur Anflüge von Argumentationen zu,
ach hör doch das nicht oder was auch immer so, finde ich falsch.
Und von daher, sie hat ein neues Album gemacht, ich blick da auch nicht mehr
durch, anscheinend kommt ihr jeden Tag irgendwie so ein Album oder so.
Es soll einfach jeder überall hören, egal wie er mag, dass irgendwelche Leute
da Meinung drüber haben, dass das irgendwie klingt wie, ach ist doch ganz schön redundant und so.
Ich meine, die Leute lesen Zizek, finden sich klug und stellen gar nicht fest,
dass der Zizek 2025 klingt wie der Zizek 2005 und er selber schon Plagiatsvorwürfe
gegen sich selber erhebt.
Was er sagt, was er sagt. Das gilt in der Musik halt auch.
Man darf das trotzdem toll finden.
Also er kritisiert aber doch jetzt hier, dass Leute die Musik kritisieren.
Und zu einem öffentlichen Diskurs gehört doch eine Debatte über Kunst.
Und bedeutet auch, dass man eine kritische Debatte über Kunst führt,
weil sonst können wir ja das Reden aufhören und dann
Jeder darf hier hören, was er will. Also ich kann mir ja auch den ganzen Tag
Heino anhören, das wird mir ja niemand verbieten.
Das ist aber ein sehr wichtiger Punkt. Jeder darf hören, was er will.
Ja, aber das muss man ja nicht nochmal eigens betonen.
Anscheinend ja doch.
Also er parodiert das ja am Anfang. Er parodiert ja am Anfang,
dass Leute behaupten, so gut sei das Album nicht.
Und es ist doch gut möglich, dass dies nicht ihr bestes Album ist und dass diese
Taylor Swift Fans und auch einige Musikkritiker sehr wohl recht haben,
wenn sie sagen, Das sind nicht besonders originale Lyriks und das ist auch nicht
sehr gut produziert oder was auch immer.
Ich stelle ja die Frage, wer will das wem sagen und warum?
Ja, das ist einfach die Debatte über die Kunst, die geführt wird über Literatur und sonst was.
Das machen wir ja im Salon auch. Weil dann kann man auch sagen,
jeder nimmt das Buch von Richard David Brecht, liest es für sich und dann schweigen wir alle dazu.
Es muss doch zu einer Gesellschaft gehören, dass man sich darüber austauscht.
Das heißt ja nicht, dass ich jemandem dadurch verbiete, irgendetwas zu hören,
sondern bedeutet ja einfach, dass ich doch inner auseinandersetzen kann.
Und da, wo die Kunst des Unterscheidens beginnt, beginnt in meinen Augen auch
erst der richtige Kunstgenuss.
Nämlich dann weiß man auch plötzlich, warum man vielleicht etwas sehr gut findet
oder anderes nicht so gut oder für welche Zwecke, welche Musik geeignet ist.
Es wäre ja auch jetzt fahrlässig zu sagen, ich stelle heute einen Komponisten
vor, Telemann ist sein Name, dass ich sage, das ist aber nicht geeignet,
um in Mallorca Party zu machen.
Das wäre ja eine völlig falsche Kategorie, die ich da anlege.
Das heißt, ich kann nicht falsche, sondern ich muss richtige Kategorien anlegen,
um Dinge zu bewerten, um damit in der Differenzierung Klarheit zu verschaffen.
Über mich selbst, über mein Hörverhalten, über aber auch die Kunstproduktion.
Und deshalb, glaube ich, ist es wichtig, dass man sich nicht dieser Kritik so verschließt.
Und was ich jetzt gerade feststelle in den sozialen Medien, ist,
dass gerade sehr reichweitenstarke Leute sich der Kritik verschließen und sich
über jede kritische Äußerung jetzt so lustig machen. Oder, wir hören uns das mal an.
Was Rezo… Aber da lassen wir ihn noch auffächern kurz.
Ja, ja.
Das Urteil über Musik ist naturgemäß
ein anderes als über ein vor allem ausgeflaggt politisches Sachbuch.
Dazwischen wäre irgendwo Literatur, darunter wäre Zizek Originalfilosophie,
vielleicht sogar Muttersprache.
Das heißt, wenn man sich einer Kritik verschließt in Sachen Musik,
geht relativ wenig kaputt.
Ich finde, sehr viel driftiger wäre das zum Beispiel beim Film,
weil es beim Film sehr viel einfacher ist, in diese Ästhetik etwas unterzujubeln,
weshalb du ja Filmkritiken machst, mit dem Hinweis auf,
achte mal auf die latenten Sinnstrukturen in diesem Film, schau nicht nur darauf,
wie dir die Faustkämpfe gefallen.
Und das droht aber bei Musik. Also ich finde auch, Musik ist so eine Art.
Ja, gerade bei Musik jetzt wieder. Denn wir haben ja bei Spotify gesehen,
wie also ein Algorithmus dafür sorgt, dass plötzlich die Komposition dem angepasst wird.
Dass sofort so eine Hookline da sein muss, dass am besten das Lied schon mit
dem Refrain beginnt, dass es in zehn Sekunden erschlossen wird,
damit es nicht weiter geskippt wird. Das verändert ja die Produktionsbedingungen.
Ich sage hier ganz deutlich, es gab immer Außeneinwirkungen auf Musik.
Wenn man eine Oper in Paris im 19.
Jahrhundert veröffentlichen wollte, dort zur Urführung bringen wollte,
musste man Ballett komponieren in die Oper hinein.
Ob das passte oder nicht, es gehörte dazu. Das heißt, solche Produktionsbedingungen
gibt es immer, aber jetzt in einer Weise.
Wie das bei Spotify monopolartig ausgeführt wird, unterstützt dann noch von
den Algorithmen der Reels bei Instagram, der TikToks und all dem,
können wir sagen, dass das ein großes Problem ist für die Musiker,
weil sie immer mehr sich dem angleichen, womit die Kreativität eigentlich geschmälert wird.
Und wir bekommen übrigens von unserem Freund, den du eben schon genannt hast,
Olli, bekomme ich fast täglich jetzt irgendwas per Instagram geschickt,
von Musikern, die mit Bands auftreten, die sich unglaublich darüber aufregen,
wie wenig sie verdienen über Spotify,
wie sehr sie nicht mehr dem Algorithmus entsprechen und deshalb aussortiert werden und, und, und.
Und wie prekär auch die Lage der meisten Künstler ist, die Musik machen.
Und deswegen finde ich es auch richtig, gerade den Mainstream zu kritisieren,
dass man auch wieder deutlich macht, es kann auch noch andere Musik geben,
womit man ja nicht den Leuten abspricht, dass sie nicht Taylor Swift hören können,
aber man kann Unterschiede machen.
Da muss man schon drauf achten, dass das eben nicht dazu führt.
Naja, also ich glaube, man muss jetzt die erfolgreichste Sängerin aller Zeiten
nicht so ganz groß davor beschützen, dass sie jetzt bald nicht mehr gehört wird.
Es geht mir nicht um Taylor Swift. Es geht mir um die, die Taylor Swift hören.
Die hören Taylor Swift, weil sie ihnen gefällt. Und zwar, und das ist halt so
diese Art von Kunst, die ich ja gerade aufgefächert als ein bisschen special,
weil man da einfach auf Play klickt und nicht weiter drüber nachdenkt.
Weil man nicht in einem Klassenraum ist, weil man gerade nicht in einem Seminar
ist, sondern weil man gerade aus der Schule kommt und sich nachmittags entspannt.
Er hat absolut seine Berechtigung. Das Problem ist ja nur, dass wir einen sehr
starken Diskurs über Taylor Swift in den Feuilletons haben, in entsprechenden
Podcasts, in denen uns Taylor Swift als die große Künstlerin verkauft wird.
Was du jetzt ja gerade schilderst, das ist Gebrauchsmusik.
Dann sind wir ja auch in einer ganz anderen Sphäre plötzlich unterwegs.
Nur wenn jemand vor mir sitzt und sagt, ja es gibt zwei große Sänger,
der eine ist Fritz Wunderlich und der andere heißt Heino, dann würde ich Widerspruch
anmelden und sagen, also Heino hat auch sein Talent für das,
was er da macht im Bierzelt, aber das ist nun jetzt nicht Fritz Wunderlich.
Ich ermundere also hier alle Schüler, die nachmittags aus der Schule kommen
und sich entspannt zu Hause einfach Taylor Swift anhören.
Sagt einfach nie, das ist Kunst. Das ist eure Gebrauchsmusik,
sie gefällt euch, das ist das Einzige, was zählt. Haut rein.
Wir hören jetzt ein Reel von Rezo, der sich jetzt äußert, denn auch Nina Chuba
hat ein neues Album veröffentlicht.
Und es gibt eine Kritik in der Zeit an diesem neuen Album von Nina Chuba und
diese Kritik nimmt sich jetzt Rezo in einem Reel vor.
Das neue Album von Nina Tschuba ist grässlich. Nina Tschuba hat ihr neues Album veröffentlicht.
Hallo, hallo. Das hier ist eine Rezension.
Die Frau heißt Juliane, die das geschrieben hat. Ich lese jetzt einfach vor,
warte. Tschuba-Songs über Dosis und unsicher sind kaum zu attraktieren.
Aus zielistischen Gründen gewählte Hyperbel, sondern im Wortsinn gemeint. Okay, nein.
Warte, wie drücke ich das aus? Ich meine das nicht als Hyperbel, was als nächstes kommt.
Wie Kunst wirkt auf Leute, ist halt extrem subjektiv. Ich weiß, das ist crazy, ne?
Deswegen ist es so wertlos, was du tust, Julian, in deinem Leben.
Und das ist nicht als Hyperbel gemeint.
Zu sagen, dass man etwas grässlich und scheiße und unhörbar findet, das kann man machen.
Aber wenn man dafür mehr als fünf
Minuten investiert, das Leuten klar zu machen, dann ist man ein Opfer.
So, das ist die Art der Auseinandersetzung jetzt. Ich habe dann dagegen einen
Kommentar bei Instagram geschrieben und du weißt, was passiert,
wenn man Rezo kritisiert, dann ist er sofort in deiner,
DMs und erzählt dann, nein, es gibt ja noch einen Stream, in dem ich das viel
differenzierter gesagt habe und mehr gesagt habe und denke ich,
ja, schreibe ich ihm ja, aber das interessiert mich ja nicht.
Du hast das ja als einzelnes Reel so veröffentlicht, wie es da ist.
Und ich finde das im höchsten Maße fahrlässig, was hier passiert.
Man kann immer darüber diskutieren, ob eine Kritik treffend ist oder nicht.
Und man kann darüber diskutieren, ob das jetzt die beste Kritik der Welt ist,
die hier in der Zeit von Juliane Liebert verfasst wurde.
Aber hier werden Sachen verdreht.
Sie beschreibt erstmal das Phänomen Nina Chuba, sagt, was sie schon gemacht
hat in ihrer Karriere, bezieht sich dann darauf, dass sie nicht ihrem eigenen
Stil weiter gefolgt ist.
Sie sagt, es ist irrsinnig schade, dass Nina Chuba nicht etwa von Wildberry
Lilith ausgehend ihren eigenen Stil, ihren eigenen Sound weiterverfolgt.
Stattdessen klingt sie inzwischen wie alle anderen.
So, das ist ja erstmal nicht eine Generalabrechnung.
Juliane Liebert hatte auch nichts gegen junge Musik. Sie ist,
ich habe mir das dann angesehen.
Ich kannte sie nicht. Man wünscht sich einen Ohrsturz herbei.
Ich komme jetzt dazu. Sie beschäftigt sich ja in der Zeit hauptsächlich mit
Popmusik und lobt auch moderne Popmusik von Taylor Swift und was weiß ich.
Es ist nicht grundsätzlich so, dass sie junge Musik ablehnt und sie schreibt
dann allgemein nicht über Nina Schuber direkt in einem Absatz.
»Leider ist ein Großteil der marktgängigen Popmusik heute präzedenzlos,
schrottig und überflüssig.
Das ist keine aus stilistischen Gründen gewählte Hyperbel, sondern im Wortsinn
gemeint krässlich, unhörbar.
So furchteinflößend grausig, so abgefucht, fakt- und austauschbar,
herzlos und geistlos, dass man einen baldigen Hörsturz fleht,
sich aus dem Taxi werfen will oder den Supermarkt niederbrennen möchte,
indem man den ganzen unerträglichen Mist zwangshören muss.«.
Dies ist eine Polemik gegen eine bestimmte Art der Popmusik,
die ich in gewisser Weise teilen kann.
Mich beschäftigt Popmusik nicht so sehr, weil ich sie einfach kaum höre,
aber das ist etwas, was wir feststellen können und was sie moniert.
Jetzt kann man sagen, das kann man anders ausdrücken, warum sich Rizzo daran
stört, dass sie hyperbel sagt, nun die Autorin ist auch noch Lyrikerin,
ihr wird dieser Begriff sehr leicht über die Lippen gehen und sie findet es nun,
dass es kein gutes Album ist.
Dass sie das hätte anders begründen können noch, tiefer begründen können,
alles geschenkt. Also Kritik an der Kritik kann man üben.
Nur was hier passiert, was Rizu hier tut, ist zu sagen, wenn du dich länger
als fünf Minuten mit sowas auseinandersetzt, dann bist du ein Opfer. Bedeutet also, die...
Tiefer gehende Auseinandersetzung mit Kunst ist überhaupt gar nicht gewünscht.
Find's toll oder lass es. Aber denk nicht länger darüber nach.
Schreib auf keinen Fall einen Verriss oder so etwas. Und das ist wirklich eine
ganz merkwürdige Unkultur, die wir jetzt in den sozialen Medien erleben.
Eben ja auch den Clip, den ich da schon abgespielt habe. Dann wird gesagt,
ja Taylor Swift hat eine Welttournee gemacht, schreib du da mal nebenher ein Album.
Da muss ich denken, ja, Francis Ford Coppola hat 20 Jahre an seinem Film,
der kürzlich erschienen ist, gearbeitet. Er ist trotzdem scheiße geworden.
Ja, also, was soll ich sagen?
Rezo hat offenbar an einem Tag in den letzten Tagen, gehörte er offenbar zu
den 700 Millionen Leuten, die auf Instagram ein Video veröffentlicht haben,
mit denen wir uns jetzt hier im Podcast befassen.
Aus Gründen, ich verstehe das, was du sagst, ich kann es trotzdem… Nein.
Was ich erlebe in den sozialen Medien ist jetzt immer mehr, dass man gerade
die Erfolgreichsten vor jeder Kritik nochmal besonders beschützen will.
Und das ist eine eigenartige Sache, die jetzt da stattfindet.
Ich bin sehr dafür, dass zur Meinungsfreiheit auch die Kritik der Kritik gehört.
Nur was hier stattfindet, dass man jetzt Leute als Opfer tituliert,
die sich die Mühe machen, einen Verriss zu schreiben und denen vorwerfen,
dass man das dann doch gleich lassen kann,
ist doch keine Herangehensweise.
Absolut. Das ist ja ein völlig irrsinniger Diskurs. Ich bringe dir noch ein
drittes Beispiel jetzt.
Ein drittes Beispiel. Du hast mitbekommen, Caroline Wahl hat einen Roman veröffentlicht.
Hat sie ihren Preis jetzt bekommen?
Sie hat den Preis nicht bekommen. Den Preis hat übrigens Dorothee Elmiger bekommen.
Deren Roman habe ich ja hier vor zwei Monaten im Salon empfohlen.
Und alle, die ihn gelesen haben, fanden ihn toll. Elena hatte nochmal einen
Textauszug in der Insta-Story. Ich habe den kurz gelesen.
Ich hatte mich ja auch gewundert, wie viel, das ist ja fast Inception-artig,
Konjunktiv, Kaskaden kann man bauen.
Ich muss sagen, ich habe es nicht so richtig genossen, diesen Textauszug zu
lesen, aber wahrscheinlich steckt da irgendwie was drin.
Wir kommen jetzt aber zu Caroline Waldi, die hat jetzt diesen Deutschen Buchpreis
nicht bekommen, ist auch nicht dafür nominiert gewesen.
Sie hat ihren dritten Roman veröffentlicht, die Assistentin.
Dieser Roman kam zum Teil überhaupt nicht gut an.
In der Literaturkritik hat man sich sehr zurückgehalten. In der Literaturkritik
generell in Deutschland wird ja vor allem jetzt porträtiert,
besucht man Autoren zu Hause oder auf Spielplätzen oder sonst wo oder beschreibt
so allgemein Phänomene, aber die Kritik ist ein bisschen in Verruf geraten,
vor allem der Verriss und übrigens auch Juliane Liebert schreibt ja zum Thema Musikkritik.
Trotzdem sind die Rezensionen zu aktuellen Popstars meist wohlwollend oder sie
vermeiden es weitgehend über eine Inhaltsangabe und ein paar Phrasen hinaus
etwas zur Musik zu sagen.
Also das ist etwas, was wir glaube ich bei der Literatur auch immer mehr erleben.
Wir erleben das auch in dem Sinne, dass dann so kurze Hypes entstehen.
Also ich hatte eigentlich vor,
im Salon zum Beispiel den Roman Lazare mitzubringen von Elio Biedermann.
Ich habe 100 Seiten gelesen, es ist nicht zum Aushalten. Ich halte das wirklich,
auch wenn es so überall gelobt wird, für kitsch, für parfümierte Literatur und
wer der Leopard gelesen hat, braucht Lazare nicht mehr zu lesen.
Deswegen habe ich mich dagegen entschieden. Ich bin auch dafür klare Urteile.
Aber was wir jetzt bei Caroline Wahl erlebt haben, ist, dass also sehr viele
aus ihrer Leser-Community den Roman nicht toll fanden und sich auch daran gestört haben,
wie sie das Hörbuch einliest, dass das nicht gut klingt, dass sie nicht sehr
gut ihren Text lesen kann.
Da habe ich Ausschnitte gehört.
Und du hast Ausschnitte davon gehört und wirst das bestätigen können.
Das ist schlimm.
Daraufhin auch gleich so Verteidigungswellen. Ja, das sind Ideolekte.
Und manche Autoren lesen, aber sie können nicht so wie ein Tagesschausprecher sprechen.
Dann wurden Leute wie Heinz Strunk, Benjamin von Stokradbare oder Martin Walser genannt.
Stimmt alles, die könnten alle nicht in der Tagesschau sein,
Walser sowieso nicht, weil er nicht mehr lebt, aber,
Ich würde sagen, bei allen drei kann man sagen, wenn sie ihre Texte lesen,
dann gewinnen die Texte dabei.
Bei Caroline Wahl, finde ich, ist es nicht der Fall. Das ist ein Urteil, das man treffen kann.
Möglicherweise sehen das andere anders. Was aber dann so gekommen ist,
ist, dass natürlich viel Hass auch ausgeschüttet wird und sich irgendwelche
Leute echauffieren darüber,
warum Caroline Wahl in 22 Bahnen über eine prekäre Familie schreibt,
wo sie doch selbst nicht aus einer prekären Familie kommt.
Das ist dieses identitätspolitische Gedöns.
Damit müssen wir uns jetzt nicht beschäftigen. Das ist ja eine irrsinnige Argumentation.
Jedenfalls gibt es Kritik, Positives, Negatives.
Es ist jedenfalls so, dass dieser Roman, jetzt der dritte, nicht so erfolgreich
zu sein scheint wie die vorangegangenen beiden.
Jedenfalls ist sie ja eine Autorin, die gerade so zu den erfolgreichsten in Deutschland zählt.
Alles gut, aber man wundert sich dann, mit welchen Pappkameraden da gearbeitet wird.
Karoline Wahl war im Podcast von Jagoda Marinic zu Gast, Freiheit Deluxe.
Und wir hören jetzt mal Jagoda Marinic, was sie zu diesem Streit um den Roman
und um Karoline Wahl zu sagen hat.
Ich würde die Folge gerne nutzen, um dir auch zu spiegeln und es vielleicht hier auch vorzusetzen,
dass du endlich so einen Literaturbetrieb, ich habe vorhin Frauen skeptisch,
aber Frauen ängstlich, sie fürchten Frauen,
völlig herausforderst, weil du einen Millionenerfolg hast, den man einem Daniel
Kehnwand vielleicht gönnt, mit seinem Duktus und mit seinem Habitus,
aber eben nicht an der Karoval.
Und ich finde es geil, dass du es machst und ich will es auch als Frau umgekehrt
sagen, ich bin auch in diesem Literaturbetrieb gesessen und wenn du jetzt sagst,
das provoziert manche, dass du viel willst, dann frage ich mich so, Alter,
die Frau formuliert, was sie will, wo sie hin will, was sie sich für sich wünscht,
welche Ziele sie, Entschuldigung Caro, welche Ziele du dir für dich setzt,
warum provoziert das andere?
Hat der deutsche Literaturbetrieb ein Problem mit erfolgreichen Autorinnen.
Ich habe nicht den Eindruck.
Ich auch nicht. Ich habe gestern gesehen, dass der Preis von einer Frau an eine
Frau übergeben wurde und sehr viele Frauen sich darüber gefreut haben und so weiter und so fort.
Der deutsche Buchpreis ging häufiger an Frauen als an Männer.
Wenn man sich mal durch die Bestsellerlisten Taschenbuch, Belletristik,
Bundesbuch, Belletristik, Broschur, Belletristik klickt, dann wird man feststellen,
dass zu 50 Prozent Frauen zu 50 Prozent Männer dort sind.
Manchmal ist es sogar so, dass mehr Frauen als Männer da sind.
Wir erleben, dass die großen Literatursendungen, sowohl das Literarische Quartett
wie der Schweizer Literaturclub, von Frauen geleitet wird.
Wir können wirklich nicht behaupten, dass.
Der Literaturbetrieb ist ein Problem für erfolgreiche Frauen.
Das ist einfach Quatsch. Nur wird hier immer diese identitätspolitische Karte
jetzt gespielt, wenn man Kritik
äußert, beziehungsweise mitunter ist diese Kritik auch mit Häme voll.
Ja, also ich finde, das muss man auch nicht machen.
Ich finde, das hilft auch der Kritik nicht weiter. Ich habe ja mit Ole sehr
ausführlich über 22 Bahnen gesprochen und das haben wir, glaube ich,
sehr analytisch getan und sogar ohne Polemik, obwohl ich doch ein Freund von Polemik bin.
Aber ich will zum Beispiel mal erinnern, dass es den Schriftsteller Takis Bürger
gibt, dessen Debütroman unglaublich gefeiert wurde.
Dann hat er irgendwann einen Roman veröffentlicht, in dem es um den Holocaust ging.
Dieser Roman wurde verrissen noch und nöcher.
Man hat ihn dann auch so dargestellt, das ist dieser Everybody's Darling,
der sich an jede Buchhändlerin zum Selfie anschmiegt und und und.
Also man hat genau so, wie man über Karolin Wajer-Zerfeld, hat man das auch
mit Huckis Burger gemacht.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass ich das gut finde, ich will nur sagen, dass das stattfindet.
Wir haben heute ja einen Autor mit Richard David Precht, in dem,
wenn es einen Artikel überhaupt nochmal in der Zeitung über ihn gibt,
immer erwähnt wird, diese schönen Haare und wie er da wieder eitel sitzt und
all das. Also es ist nicht so, als würden die mit Kritik geschont werden.
Und um einfach nochmal das ein bisschen zu verstehen, was hier passiert,
wir konzentrieren uns die ganze Zeit auf diese super, super, super Stars.
Die natürlich auch wichtig sind für Verlage, weil die Verlage oft mit Querfinanzierung funktionieren.
Immer weniger funktioniert es aber für die Verlage, weil diese Erfolgsautoren
enorme Vorschüsse bekommen.
Es ist ein Wettstreit, wer bekommt den höchsten Vorschuss und sie können den
gar nicht mehr einspielen. Das hat sich ja jetzt in der Vergangenheit bei mehreren
großen Autoren gezeigt, dass sie Rekordvorschüsse bekommen haben.
Da konnten sie sich jetzt einspielen, die Verlage werden immer nervöser.
Am Ende wird der Druck nach unten abgegeben. Der Roman von Dorothee Elmiger,
ich wage mich soweit vorzusagen, ohne den Buchpreis, ohne diese Nominierung
all das, hätte der sich vielleicht, wenn es gut kommt, 10.000, 12.000 Mal verkauft.
Ein sensationeller Roman. Wir können davon ausgehen, dass in dieser Saison viele
sensationelle Romane weit unter 10.000 Verkäufe liegen werden.
Das ist die Situation gerade am Buchmarkt. Und die Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie funktioniert so,
dass wir uns jetzt nur auf die Stars ausrichten und dann die ganze Zeit darüber
reden, wie wurden sie irgendwo behandelt und hat der Literaturbetrieb da ein
Problem mit einer Bestsellerautorin.
Ich will mal in Erinnerung rufen,
wie mit Autoren in der Vergangenheit mit Männlichen umgegangen wurde.
Ich sehe, es kommt jetzt Marcel Reichranitzki, was ich natürlich sehr gut finde.
Ich möchte nicht in ihn hineinquatschen mit Argumenten, die ich eigentlich jetzt loswerden möchte.
Also jemand macht ein großes Album und groß im Sinne von, ist schon erfolgreich,
ziemlich sicher von allen Beteiligten, wird ein nächster Bestseller und so.
Das sind ja die super, super, super Stars, die du gerade meintest.
Dann verhalten sich Leute dazu. Ich möchte jetzt gerne einfach alle Grenzen verwischen.
Wenn Taylor Swift ein Album macht, kann man das anhören und sich zu dieser Musik verhalten.
Aber wir wissen alle, heute geht es ja nicht nur um die Musik,
die man für sich alleine hört, denn man hat ja Internets und First,
Second, Third Screens und kann überall seine Meinung bekunden.
Also gehört zum Phänomen dieser Albumveröffentlichung, dass sich Leute dazu
verhalten und man möchte gerne in diesem Diskurs mit sein.
Also, jemand macht eine Musik und du forderst, diese Musik darf,
muss kritisiert werden.
Wir brauchen diesen kritischen Diskurs über wer auch immer ein Album veröffentlicht.
Ich sage jetzt, jemand macht ein Album, ja, Kritik daran muss möglich sein.
Wenn diese Kritik daran kommt, gilt für den, der diese Kritik kritisiert, genau dasselbe.
Jeder, Rezo, der Typ, jeder darf irgendwelche Kritiken in sich rausnehmen.
Ich finde ja auch, Rezo hat einen inhaltlichen Fehler gemacht.
Ich brauche keine Aufklärung, Rezo, schreib mir keine DMen.
Wenn in diesem Text eine allgemeine Aussage gemacht wird über die Popmusik und
dann scheidet man ja lieber die Ohren ab, dann sagt das ja gar nichts über das
Nina Chuba Album aus, denn das ist ja nur Anlass für diesen Text.
Wenn man also mit dieser Kritik gar nicht umgehen kann, weil man nicht in der
Lage ist, einen Text richtig zu lesen, weil man nicht versteht,
dass Absatz 3 vielleicht einen Brückenschlag Absatz 2 drin hat und gar nichts
mehr so viel mit Absatz 1 zu tun hat.
Ist das durchaus ein Problem, kann man auch kritisieren, nur auch diese Kritik
ist dann wieder genauso berechtigt wie jede andere Kritik auch.
Also von daher, wenn jemand ein neues Album macht, einen neuen Film,
wie auch immer, Feuer frei, macht Reaction-Videos zu Reaction-Videos von Reaction-Videos,
Jeder darf alles machen.
Hat, wir sind nicht mehr in der Gatekeeper-Struktur. Die Literaturkritik oder
auch die Musikkritik ist schwächer denn je, weil plötzlich die Leute,
die zum Beispiel Musik produzieren, sich zu Wort melden können.
Sie können sagen, nein, nein, das ist aber so und so gemeint oder hier,
trotzdem kauft mein Album, was auch immer. Diese Möglichkeit bestand früher in dieser Weise nicht.
Zudem gibt es Communities, Leserschaften, die sich äußern können.
Nur, das war ja dann auch im Fall von Caroline Wald so, dass da sehr viele aus
ihrem Publikum gesagt haben, aber den dritten finde ich nicht so gut,
was man ja auch akzeptieren kann.
Ich finde auch manche Regisseure toll und dann enttäuschen sie mich zwei, dreimal nach Gang.
Das ist so, das kann so sein, das mag auch daran liegen, dass man nicht immer
auf einer Höhe abliefern kann, was auch immer daran liegt.
Nur muss man das mal akzeptieren und dass dann hier so gesagt wird,
ja mit Daniel Kehmann ist das anders.
Also ich will da auch nochmal, es sind hier überall so kleine Unschärfen drin.
Die Karolin Emke hat gerade also klar, die hat die Genderkarte gezogen,
aber ja in Bezug auf und also nicht, dass es Frauen da gibt in dem Betrieb,
sondern dass sie sagt Das ist Jagoda Marinic.
Oder Jagoda Marinic. Sorry, ich habe mich da über Unschärfe reingebracht,
aber für mich ist das alles also die Jagoda Marinic hat gerade gesagt,
Du hast dich als Frau hingestellt und eine Forderung gestellt,
nämlich einen Preis zu bekommen.
Und da würde ich sagen, zeigt mir den Mann, insbesondere Daniel Kehlmann,
der das jemals gemacht hat.
Daniel Kehlmann hat dieses Land verlassen, Europa verlassen,
der lebt irgendwo in New York, weil er einfach seine Ruhe haben will und sagt,
hier ist mein neues Buch, macht daraus, was ihr wollt, dass dann alle ein Theaterstück
daraus machen und wie auch immer. Damit hat Daniel Keman relativ wenig zu tun.
Ich habe jedenfalls keine Titelthesen Temperamente vor Augen,
in denen er den großen, ich bin ja gerade im Interview, also ich nutze die Gelegenheit
und fordere einen Preis.
Genau das gibt es nicht. Und das hat aber Karolin Wahl gemacht und es ist natürlich
total erwähnenswert, weil es auch total funny ist, dass jemand so einen Preis
für sich einfordert und da Instagram-Stories dazu macht.
Und das muss man natürlich, wenn ich sage jetzt mit Absicht,
nicht kritisieren dürfen, sondern darüber muss man sich lustig machen dürfen,
weil es einfach super funny ist.
Also wenn ich jetzt sage, gebt mir die Sendung von Karim Miosga,
dann muss ich damit rechnen, dass Leute sich darüber lustig machen.
Das ist einfach so. Und bei Daniel Kehmann ist es ja auch so,
dass zum Beispiel sein Roman F so leidlich gut bei der Kritik ankam.
Ich erinnere mich, wie da LK Heidenreich sich unglaublich drüber aufgeregt hat.
Ich erinnere mich, dass er das Drehbuch geschrieben hat zu Felix Krull,
zu der neuen Felix Krull-Verfilmung. Und ich erinnere mich da an einen Kritiker,
der wirklich getobt hat, wie grauenhaft dieser Film ist.
Und dieser Kritiker, weißt du, wer das war? Das war ich.
Also es ist nicht so, als würde man mit Kritik sparen.
Einen Punkt muss ich jetzt unbedingt noch machen, bevor wir mal zeigen.
Ich finde, um es jetzt ganz auf die Spitze zu treiben.
Ja, ich habe gerade Carolin Wall kritisiert dafür, dass sie einen Buchpreis
für sich fordert, was ja im Subtext bedeutet, ich finde mein Buch selber so
gut, bitte gib mir einen Preis.
Ich finde, nachdem ich jetzt auch große, große Kunstmuseen in Lissabon gesehen
habe und die sind natürlich voll stolz auf ihren Surrealismus und so weiter,
den sie da zeigen können und haben dann gleich gezeigt,
okay, nicht nur wir auf der iberischen Halbinsel, sondern es gibt das auch in
der Schweiz und Dings, da haben sie sogar einen Transatlantic Drift drin,
um da nochmal Jackson Pollock, der auch mal so ein paar figurative Sachen,
aber halt total kubistisch und so.
Ich finde, wenn man in diese Museen geht, heute, ich mache einfach ein Foto
von diesem Riesentext an der Wand und lasse mir den dann vorlesen.
Ich finde, diese Bilder hängen zu sehr für sich alleine.
Mich nervt es total, dass ich an ein Bild herantrete und da steht einfach Untitled.
So im Sinne von, der Künstler sagt, das sollst du selbst entdecken.
Ich gebe dir gar keinen Beipackzettel.
Ich finde, Beipackzettel sind jetzt ein Qualitätsmerkmal.
Also ich finde nicht, jemand sollte für sich einen Preis fordern.
Oder auf die Dokumenta gehen, da bekommst du wieder alles erklärt.
Ja, Dokumenta ist, ich klammer jetzt Maus. Ich finde, wenn jemand Kunst macht,
Musik macht, ich habe das sehr genossen, auf diese Art fair zu sein hier in Frankfurt.
Also einfach in der hinterletzten Messerhalle ist halt so eine Ecke.
Jeder Künstler mietet sich für 3000 Euro am Wochenende so einen Stand und bringt
ein oder zwei Kunstwerke mit, ist selber vor Ort und erklärt, worum es hier geht.
Man kann Rückfragen stellen und so weiter und so fort. Und das finde ich zum
Beispiel, das kann man jetzt auch mal, nicht nur Kritiker, auch die Künstler
selbst, können jetzt mal ein bisschen Schauatelier machen.
Ja, können sie machen, aber ich bin generell nicht so für diese Beipackzettel-Kunst.
Ich bin für lebendige Kunst, ja. Bei uns im Vöhrtag haben wir immer die Literatur
und das literarische Leben.
Und wir haben einen Reader-Scan gemacht und weißt du, was die Leute lesen?
Das literarische Leben.
Ja, und da bin ich nicht so dafür. Ich mag auch nicht so gerne Porträts lesen,
sondern ich lese lieber Kritiken oder Debatten.
Wir erinnern uns jetzt an das literarische Quartett.
Wir sind in den 90er Jahren. Günter Grass hat seinen großen Wenderoman veröffentlicht, Ein weites Feld.
Man hat Marcel Reich-Ranitzki dann schon, bevor die Sendung aufgezeichnet wurde,
auf dem Spiegelcover gesehen, wie er den Roman von Krass nicht nur im Text verreißt, sondern zerreißt.
Jetzt hören wir noch einmal Marcel Reich-Ranitzki dazu, um mal zu sagen,
das ist jetzt nicht so ein Angriff gegen erfolgreiche Autorinnen,
nur das mit drastischen Worten um sich geworfen wird.
Zu. Du spielst das auch aus Unterhaltungszwecken.
Ganz richtig. Und ich sage auch hier gleich dazu, dass wenn ich mir heute alte
Folgen ansehe, mich das zwar immer noch unterhält, dass ich aber,
was das literarische Urteil anbelangt, viel häufiger bei Sigrid Löffler bin als bei Reich Ranitzky.
... niedriger. Noch niedriger können wir es nicht.
Das ist ja schon... Wir sagen, es ist wertlose, prosa, langweilig und unlesbar.
Und die sagen, wir sollen es niedriger sein. Wenn Sie das Buch vom Jahrhundertereignis
etwas niedriger hängen... Dann bleibt es ein genauso schlechtes Buch wie jetzt.
Wenn dieses Buch von Siegfried Lenz geschrieben wäre oder von Stefan Haib...
Dann hätten wir es nicht behandelt hier. Dann würden Sie es dulden.
Und dann würden Sie es leben lassen. Ach dulden, ich lasse...
Dann würden Sie es leben lassen, dass Sie... Nein, ich kann etwas,
was tot ist, nicht leben lassen.
Ich kann etwas, was tot ist, nicht leben lassen.
Sie haben es ja tot geredet. Nein, nein, passen Sie mal auf.
Es gibt Autoren, die mit einem ersten Buch fabelhaft angefangen haben.
Ja, das gehört dazu. Thomas Mann hat im Leben einen Roman wie die Buddenbrot nicht geschrieben.
Es gibt nicht viele Autoren, die wirklich ihr ganzes Leben hindurch eine gewisse Qualität halten.
Niemand verlangt von ihm, dass er immer dieselbe Ebene hält.
Aber das ist ein Buch, das total wertlos und langweilig ist.
Nein, ist es nicht. Von der ersten bis zur letzten Zeit.
Ja, und so weiter und so fort. Wir hören noch als zweites Beispiel eine Auseinandersetzung,
ganz kurz, nur Reich-Radinsky, da zu einem Roman von Martin Walser mit dem Titel
Ein springender Brunnen.
Das geht mir nicht. Es geht mir eine andere Sache in diesem ganzen Roman.
Ich bin überzeugt und ich bitte mich hier nicht zu brüllen, gleich vor lauter Empörung.
Er kann viel, dieser Martin Walzer. Erzählen kann er uns verrecken nicht.
Er weiß überhaupt nicht, was erzählen ist.
Ja, also das über einen Roman-Schriftsteller zu sagen ist somit das härteste
Urteil, was es überhaupt gibt.
Ich bin da gar kein Fan davon, das in solcher Drastik laufend vorzuführen und
ich finde auch, dass er gerade im Punkt Martin Walser Unrecht hat bei Ein weites
Feld, kann ich ihm da durchaus beipflichten.
Jedenfalls geht es einfach mir darum, noch mal auszulösen.
Es ist nicht alles nur gestern erst passiert, sondern wir haben eine sehr lange
Geschichte der Literaturkritik und die bedeutet auch, die Überspitzung bedeutet
diese Polemik, bedeutet auch, dass sich Autoren wiederum da ärgern.
Zum Beispiel ja Martin Weiser, der dann Tod eines Kritikers schreibt,
um sich an Marcel Reich-Ranicki zu rächen.
Auch das gab es damals schon. Aber dass man heute gerade in den sozialen Medien
die Kritik so abqualifiziert und Leute dann sogar als Opfer hinstellt,
die sich die Mühe machen, einen Verriss zu schreiben, das finde ich falsch.
Die Kritik an der Kritik finde ich wiederum sehr wichtig und eigentlich wäre
das ja wunderbar, wenn das jetzt alles die Debatte beleben würde und wir versuchen
würden wieder über Kunst und Kunstkritik zu sprechen, versuchen zu differenzieren.
Was aber stattfindet ist, dass man jetzt so tut, als sei da jemand ein Opfer,
als müsse man jetzt so eine Lagerbildung betreiben, statt über die Literatur zu reden.
Das ist nämlich auch interessant in diesem eben gehörten Ausschnitt aus dem
Podcast da mit Jagoda Marinic und Caroline Wahl. Sie sprechen nämlich gar nicht über die Literatur.
Sie reden 90 Minuten, aber wie eigentlich diese Literatur verfasst ist,
wo die literarischen Vorbilder sind.
Sie sind zum Teil nämlich auch bei Irmgard Coyne und anderen zu finden.
Darüber wird nicht gesprochen und so gibt es nur noch diese Meta-Ebene,
auf der irgendwas diskutiert wird.
Das halte ich für falsch und es dient auch überhaupt nicht der Literatur,
die sowieso einen immer prekären Status hat.
Ich kann mich noch daran erinnern, wie Herbert Grönemeyer mal bei Markus Kafka
in der Sendung war und er so eine Frage zu der Instrumentalisierung eines Grönemeyer-Liedes
hatte und Grönemeyer sagte,
Das erste Mal, dass ich da gefragt werde. Sonst aber nur so diese einzelnen
Sätze, die dann irgendwie so totgequatscht werden.
Achtet mal darauf, Albumvorstellungen, irgendwelche Musikvorstellungen,
wenn das bei Aspekte ist, Kulturzeit, da sind die Künstler im Interview,
die sagen irgendetwas, aber die werden meistens nicht zur Musik direkt befragt.
Da hört man nie irgendwas über ein Gitarrensolo oder so.
So, damit kommen wir zu aktuellen Sachen. Zum einen Aufklärung.
Wir hatten über die Antibabypille geredet, weil wir über Migration dazu kamen.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr so genau.
Es ging um den Club of Rome. Dass der Club of Rome von der Überbevölkerung ausging.
Und ich sagte dann, naja, es hat ja schon die Antibabypille gegeben.
Insofern hätte das der Club of Rome ja rezipieren können.
Und dann meintest du, Die Antibabypille kam später und jetzt ist es so,
die Antibabypille kam tatsächlich schon 1961,
also der Club of Rome war darüber dann schon zehn Jahre fast unterrichtet,
dass es sie gibt, aber du hast jetzt nochmal genauer nachgelesen,
wie die Auswirkung dieser Pille war.
Also wir lesen gleich nochmal, wir lassen uns vorlesen von Friederik,
was in der Wikipedia dazu steht. Das ist nämlich wirklich eigentlich auch interessant.
Die Antibabypille ist mir zuletzt in der Diskussion begegnet,
als ich bei Lanz saß und neben mir Rainer Hank plötzlich meinte,
ja da gab es ja die Antibabypille und einen Pillenknick und so.
Und der Pillenknick spielte bei mir weder in der Kinderwüste noch in der alten
Republik noch irgendwie eine Rolle.
Und ich will es kurz erklären, in den 70ern. Also was bei mir immer eine Rolle spielt, ist ja,
heute werden Menschen alt, denen die Gesellschaft kein Angebot macht,
während die Gesellschaft diesen alten Menschen damals, als sie jung waren,
ein Angebot gemacht hat, das so lautete, ach so, du möchtest etwas lernen?
Ja, dann bauen wir dir das größte Gebäude der Welt und zwar genau dahin, wo du es haben willst.
Uni Bochum, Uni Bielefeld, Uni was auch immer.
Das sind die von dem umbauten Volumen wirklich größten Gebäude der Welt.
Also auch ein amerikanisches Hochhaus hält da einfach nicht mit.
Wenn man sich die Uni Bielefeld anschaut, das ist für 20.000 Leute ausgelegt.
Da ging der Generalschlüssel verloren in den Besetzungszeiten,
als Studiengebühren eingeführt wurden.
Und dann hieß es, da müssen wir jetzt 10.000 Schlösser austauschen.
Also das sind die Gebäude, von denen wir da reden. So, wir hatten gleichzeitig
zu dieser Explosion von Universitäten Containerschifffahrt.
68 ist das erste Containerschiff gefahren.
Das heißt eine Explosion an Möglichkeiten, Globalisierung, Biografiegestaltung im Grunde.
Das man dann auch noch verhütet hat, schön und gut, aber der Schalter wurde
eigentlich im Kopf umgelegt, nicht in der Medizin. Man hat einfach gesagt, Kinder?
Nö, ich mache doch jetzt Karriere und so. Also das war dieser Knickpunkt.
Und es spiegelt sich ganz wunderbar in dieser Anti-Baby-Pillen-Geschichtsschreibung
in der Wikipedia wieder.
Wir hören hier mal drei Absätze.
Anti-Baby-Pille war nach ihrer Markteinführung derart revolutionär und wurde
gesellschaftlich und politisch so wenig akzeptiert,
dass sie bis Ende der 1960er Jahre in Westdeutschland nur von sehr wenigen Ärzten
und auch von diesen nur mit großer Zurückhaltung und ausschließlich als Mittel
zur Behebung von Menstruationsstörungen und zudem nur an verheiratete Frauen verschrieben wurde,
die schon drei oder vier Kinder hatten und über 30 Jahre alt waren.
So lag der Anteil der hormonell verhütenden Frauen Ende 1964 noch unter 0,3%
und 1965 bis 1966 bei 1 bis 2%.
Zudem erschütterte der Kontergarn-Skandal, über den mit Beginn des Kontergarn-Prozesses
im Mai 1968 intensiv in den Medien berichtet wurde, sowie Berichte über krebsauslösende
Wirkungen bestimmter Wirkstoffkombinationen der Antibabypille im Tierversuch 1969,
das Vertrauen der Öffentlichkeit in die Arzneimittelsicherheit und die Zuverlässigkeit
der Risikostudien und führten zur Zurückziehung einer Reihe von hormonellen
Verhütungspräparaten und einem zeitweiligen Rückgang des Interesses an der hormonellen
Schwangerschaftsverhütung.
Erst Ende 1970 lockerte die Ärzteschaft. Nach Entwarnung durch neue positive Studienergebnisse,
BCGL, Krebs- und Thromboserisiken und der darauf erfolgenden Veröffentlichung
der Lauze Leitsätze zur Verordnung oraler Ovulationshemmer und breit angelegte
Schulungsangebote für die Ärzteschaft durch die Ärztekammer.
Ihre restriktive Haltung gegenüber der Pille. Danach begann der Absatz hormoneller
Verhütungsmittel rasant zu steigen, auf 25,6% Ende 1971 und erreichte im Jahr
1976 in Westdeutschland mit einem Anteil von 32,8% Frauen,
die mit der Pille verhüteten, den damaligen Höchstwert.
Da kommen ja auch noch zwei weitere Punkte hinzu.
Also erstmal der Punkt, der zu nennen ist, in den 60er Jahren gibt es die Pillen-Enzyklika
des Papstes, der sich dagegen ausspricht, gegen die Pille.
Und nochmal zu den Zahlen jetzt, dass dann plötzlich so viele Frauen die Pille
nehmen. Das hängt natürlich auch mit zwei Dingen zusammen.
Einmal gibt es eine sexuelle Liberalisierung, die stattfindet und zugleich gibt
es aber noch eine patriarchale Struktur, die auch dafür sorgt,
dass Männer sagen, um die Verhütung kümmere ich mich nicht, mach du das, wenn du willst.
So und das ist glaube ich, was da zusammenkommt in den 70ern auch nochmal interessant.
Aber es ist erstaunlich, war mir auch nicht klar, wie lange sich diese Pille
nicht durchgesetzt hat, beziehungsweise nur in verschwindend kleineren Prozent.
Genau, also wenn man immer Pillenknick hört oder andere historische Phänomene,
bei denen man rückblickend so, ja klar, voll das revolutionäre Produkt hat natürlich
die Gesellschaft umgekrempelt.
Ne, so einfach ist es dann immer nicht.
Und so auch ein kleiner Kommentar von mir, wenn ich jetzt Kolumnen schreibe,
dann werde ich eine Kolumne schreiben.
Donald Trump wird gerade von allen der Nobelpreis verliehen,
des Herzens, weil er hat die Geiseln heim geholt.
Das hat ja nicht mal Netanyahu geschafft oder was auch immer jetzt so kommentiert wird.
Zwei Jahre lang haben uns die deutschen Journalisten erklärt,
Netanyahu braucht freie Hand. Wir haben eine deutsche Verantwortung.
Egal was da stattfindet, können wir jetzt später drüber reden,
welche Begriffe wir wählen. Es muss geschehen.
Wir müssen Waffen liefern, es darf gar nichts und so weiter.
Kritik ziemt sich nicht, gerade für Deutschland.
Genau, gerade für Deutschland. Und Netanyahu muss machen dürfen,
was er will. Und außerdem hat
er ja diese rechtsradikale Regierung und da kann er ja gar nicht anders.
Dann von heute auf morgen, wie so ein Corona-Pivot in China,
wird uns erklärt, also wie der Donald Trump den Netanyahu gezügelt hat.
Habt ihr alle dieses Foto gesehen, wie ihm das Telefon gereicht hat,
gesagt hat, du rufst jetzt bei Peter an und entschuldigst dich dafür,
dass du ihm heute das Eis weggegessen hast. Also,
Und manchmal denke ich mir so, also ich sehe diesen Journalismus und komme aus
dem Staunen nicht raus, ehrlich gesagt.
Und damit sind wir doch schon bei unserem Thema des Angststillstands,
denn nur aus so einer Angst, was darf ich denn jetzt gerade sagen?
Achso, jetzt ist Trump okay, jetzt ist mit Netanyahu, darf man ihn einhegen,
muss man ihn einhegen, Trump hat es auch gesagt, alle Journalisten sagen es,
Döpfner ist auch zufrieden mit Trump, okay, dann Feuer frei.
Aber da ist noch mehr das Cursor-Bild.
Das ist Cursor-Bild. Wir kommen ja auch nochmal darauf zu sprechen.
Er erwähnt das nochmal. Der Cursor-Journalismus, den können wir da wirklich in Reinform sehen.
Ich war auch erstaunt, du hast es so schön jetzt gerade nochmal beschrieben.
Wir sprechen also jetzt über Angststillstand, warum die Meinungsfreiheit schwindet
von Richard David Precht.
Darüber werden wir diskutieren ausführlich.
Außerdem haben wir auch wieder Empfehlungen, denn es gibt ja auch noch andere
Literatur, zum Beispiel das Gute Übel, ein Band mit Erzählungen der argentinischen
Schriftstellerin Samantha Schweblin.
Wir hatten schon mal ein Buch von ihr, also ich hatte schon mal eins vorgestellt
und jetzt hier ein weiteres mit wirklich ganz beeindruckenden Erzählungen.
Ja, da du den Buch mal kennst, auf der Shortlist stand ja wohl auch ein Buch,
habe ich nur ganz kurz gehört, bei Andruck oder so, von einem damaligen Fünftklässler,
als Robert Steinhäuser in Erfurt 20 Lehrer erschossen hat.
Ja, Kaleb Erdmann habe ich noch nicht gelesen, bin aber sehr gespannt darauf.
Da würde mich mal interessieren.
Weil da ist ja dann wirklich wichtig, wer schreibt.
Ja, vor allem, weil er auch mit dem Autofiktionalen wohl zu spielen scheint.
Ich bin auch sehr gespannt auf diesen Roman. Ich bin noch nicht dazu gekommen.
Vielleicht ist das was für den nächsten Salon.
Dann wissen wir, der Goldpreis steigt immer weiter.
Wir lesen mal in der Ortsklärung nach, was dann passiert, wenn der steigt. Nämlich dann...
Boomt der illegale Bergbau in Ghana und das ist so verheerend,
unglaublich das zu lesen.
Außerdem geht es um die neue Friedensnobelpreisträgerin, ein Autor in der Süddeutschen
Zeitung, äußert Kritik, sehr gute Kritik, wie ich finde.
Wir sprechen ja hier nicht nur mit Precht über Meinungsfreiheit,
sondern auch sonst, wie gehen wir um mit TikTok, soziale Medien,
verbieten für Kinder, Jugendliche, was auch immer.
Sofort verbieten.
Ist aufgefallen, dass ich schon jetzt in mehreren Runden saß,
in denen dann immer wieder darauf verwiesen wurde, dass die Leopoldina doch
so ein Diskussionspapier dazu rausgegeben hat.
Und ich dachte, Leopoldina, habe ich zuletzt gehört, wir müssen nochmal eine
Schule schließen, Corona und so weiter.
Soll ich das überhaupt lesen? Ich habe es dann gelesen.
Wir gehen mal auf die Punkte ein. Es ist also gar nicht so schlimm und glaube
ich, wir könnten vielleicht einen Kompromiss finden, wir zwei,
während wir darüber sprechen.
Ich bin mal sehr gespannt, wenn ich schon wieder Leopoldina höre.
Ja, ja, ja, aber die sind eher näher an die als an mir, sage ich dir, mein Lieber.
Also wir werden im Oktober noch darauf zurückkommen. Ich hatte mich ja sehr
vehement und habe dir das auch sehr wuchtig dargelegt. Ich will nicht hören,
was irgendwelche Politiker dazu sagen. Ich warte nicht auf Gesetze.
Es hat ein paar Leute irritiert und ich verstehe auch warum.
Ich will jetzt schon mal ankündigen, wir reden Ende des Monats über dieses Mieterbegehren
in Berlin, in dem ein konkreter Gesetzestext geschrieben wird.
Also keine Aufforderung an den Senat oder überhaupt, sondern 80% der Leute in
Berlin wohnen zur Miete.
Und die machen eine Mehrheitsentscheidung, hoffentlich, mal sehen,
wo einfach im Gesetz steht, mehr als 3000 Wohnungen darfst du nicht haben,
wird verstaatlicht, enteignet, vergesellschaftet, wie auch immer.
Es gibt offenbar selbst in noch ziemlich, sagen wir mal, internationalen Vergleich,
gefestigten Demokratien wie in Deutschland.
Umwege, um einfach zu sagen, der parlamentarische Politikbetrieb hat vollständig
versagt. Wir ignorieren ihn ab jetzt.
Ja, interessant.
Und das finde ich sehr gut. Dieses Berliner Beispiel, finde ich,
ist einfach nur Chiffre, Miete.
Aber wir haben da, und es ist auch nicht einfach Volksentscheid oder irgendwas,
sondern da sitzen Leute da, die sich ernsthafte Gedanken über den konkreten
Gesetzestext machen und machen ihn kollektiv bindend, weil die Bevölkerung das
will, unabhängig des parlamentarischen Betriebs.
Und das finde ich ein sehr interessantes Phänomen und ich hoffe natürlich,
dass man daraus eine Entwicklung machen kann.
Um zum Beispiel auch, ja, englische, amerikanische, deutsche Politiker wollen
irgendwie ausbeuten, dass ja hier Kritik, Eltern wollen ihre Kinder schützen
und deswegen machen wir jetzt Überwachungstechnologie.
Ja, du hast es ja bei Ben auch wunderbar sofort auf den Punkt gebracht,
eine Waffenverbotszone ist keine Waffenverbotszone.
Sie ist eine, die Polizei darf dich hier durchsuchen Zone.
Und nur weil das Gesetz anders heißt, das muss dann einfach umgangen werden, sowas, ja.
Und das, auf dieses Phänomen, auf das ich sehr viel setze, kommen wir noch zurück.
Und deswegen Leopoldina, okay?
Ich bin weniger skeptisch jetzt, als ich es dann gelesen habe,
habe ich mich dann eines besseren Belehrnissen.
Aber es gibt auch da Punkte, die ich wiederum heikel finde.
Da müssen wir dann nochmal drüber reden. Und es gibt noch Musik von Georg Philipp
Telemann, die ich empfehle.
Sehr gut. Wir lesen heute meinerseits, ich trage die Zahlen vor,
warum sind die Liberalen so glücklich, also unglücklich, warum sind die Konservativen so glücklich.
Wir haben ja über die Zahlen des Einkommens schon gesprochen.
Es ist egal, welche Metrik man nimmt, es ist erschütternd. Und danach,
nachdem du dann Texte vorgestellt hast, komme ich auf dieses Thema zurück aus der anderen Richtung.
In der FAZ wurde darüber geschrieben, warum immer mehr Frauen Single sein wollen
und bleiben wollen. Also sagen, ich verlasse nicht nur den Mann,
ich verlasse die ganze Idee.
So, da kann man sich also über dieses Unglück dann nochmal spezifisch Gedanken machen.
Dann ein Text aus The New Atlantis, eine Publikation, die ich erst kürzlich
entdeckt habe, die mir aber sehr gut gefällt.
Da wird einfach monatlich oder so Texte publiziert über das erste Forschungs-
und Marktgebiet, bei dem China die Schlüsseltechnologie,
die dann auch Markt und so weiter relevant ist, vor Amerika vorstellt.
Und das ist KI in Verbindung mit Genetik.
Also da wird es gruselig.
Und als wir darüber sprachen, dass Mangold uns den Christen,
Antichristen, Catechon und so weiter vorstellte und dann darauf hinwies,
das ist auch ganz interessant mit Blick auf Amerika und wie das im Salon gesprochen haben,
hat Peter Thiel vier Vorlesungen gehalten in San Francisco zu diesem Thema.
Ich habe das dann meinem Gemini gegeben und gesagt, guck mal hier,
ist das noch aufgetaucht? Also wow, das ist ja krass und so.
Also wir gehen diese vier Vorlesungen durch. Die gibt es aber noch nicht im Original.
Der Guardian hat sich darum gekümmert, sie relativ detailliert vorzustellen
und Adrian Daub hat sie auch noch kommentiert.
Es ist, man kommt aus dem Staunen nicht heraus. Es ist wirklich unglaublich.
Ich will nicht sagen, es ist unglaublich gruselig, sondern es ist,
ich möchte es gerne auf die, es ist unglaublich albern. Man kann es sich nicht vorstellen.
Wie es in diesen Köpfen der amerikanischen Milliardärer davor geht.
Das alles gibt es im Salon. Den Salon kann man abonnieren, wenn man bei Apple...
Darf ich noch kurz auf den Termin hinweisen? Ich habe einen Termin in Jena angenommen.
Der ist aber schon am Dienstag, am 21.
Nächste Woche. 21. Oktober bin ich in Jena. Infos dazu auf meiner Webseite,
dass der Termin verlinkt.
Prima, ich bin am 27.10. in Berlin und dann noch im November in Essen, in Prag.
Wir sind in Düsseldorf, auch das kann man dann bald sehen. Wir reden in Düsseldorf
über KI. Wir reden in Düsseldorf im Filmmuseum, glaube ich, wird das stattfinden.
Wow, steht da auch ein Alien hier in Frankfurt, steht ein Alien im Filmmuseum.
Wir werden nachschauen. Werden wir über KI reden? Also auch da gibt es das,
wenn gleich wir dieses Gespräch auch aufzeichnen werden und dann für die Salon
Abonnenten auch noch im Nachtrag veröffentlichen können. Das ist also Ende November.
Ich glaube auf meiner Homepage ist schon der Termin oder wird dann da bald folgen.
Jetzt noch ein Punkt, genau. Wir freuen uns, wenn ihr den Salon unterstützt,
wenn ihr also in den Salon kommt.
Dort sprechen wir ausführlich über die jetzt genannten Titel.
Vor allem werden wir diskutieren, so etwa zwei Stunden über Angststillstand
von Richard David Precht.
Was können wir mit diesen Thesen machen?
Und man hat natürlich dann auch Zugang zu allen alten Folgen,
auch zu den Live-Salons, die es ja fünfmal im Jahr inzwischen gibt.
Und in den Salon kommt man ganz einfach.
Erstmal, wenn man bei Apple ist und gerne auch da bleiben will und nicht irgendwas
anderes machen möchte, zu Steady rübergehen möchte, dann kann man das einfach über Apple abonnieren.
Man kann, wenn man bei Patreon ist, auch dort den Salon abonnieren.
Wir empfehlen allerdings Steady.
Dort hat man die beste Übersicht, hat auch diese Kapiteleinteilung am schönsten aufgegliedert.
Und deswegen ist das unsere präferierte Plattform, ein Unternehmen aus Berlin,
bei dem es eigentlich auch nie Probleme gibt. Und ganz wichtig nochmal zu sagen.
Man kann diesen Podcast, also der Salon ist ja einfach nur ein Podcast,
den kann man überall hören, wie man jeden anderen Podcast auch hört.
Man muss nicht vor dem Desktop sitzen und dort die Steady-Seite aufrufen oder
so etwas, sondern man pflegt den RSS-Feed einfach ein in den Podcatcher.
Die meisten hören tatsächlich über Spotify, auch darüber kann man das dann hören
und es gibt keine Friktionen, dann man muss es nur einmal einrichten und wir
freuen uns, wenn ihr dabei seid.
Genau. Außerdem gibt es auf der Webseite verlinkt das Salon Archiv.
Es sind jetzt alle Salons aufgeführt mit allen Kapitelmarken und oben gibt es ein Suchfeld.
Man könnte also nach Toos suchen, steht da 12 Erwähnungen.
Und dann sind genau die, wo Toos auch vorkommt, unten aufgelistet.
Also da kann man sich jetzt endlich Übersicht verschaffen. Das wird es natürlich
für den allgemeinen Podcast auch noch geben, aber da will ich natürlich gleich
eine KI suchen, deswegen muss ich da noch ein bisschen Vibe coden.
Ich rufe da auch nochmal nach Hilfe auf, spezifischer Hilfe,
denn es ist gar nicht so einfach, die großen Kapitel, die großen Podcast-Transkripte
in diese kleinen Chunks einzuteilen, sodass man überhaupt darauf zugreifen kann,
weil keine KI kann 50 fünfstündige Transkripte durchsuchen.
Also da stoßen alle an ihre Grenzen, aber zumindest die Salonsuche gibt es schon mal.
Also für alle, die schon Salonmitglieder sind, die können einfach sich die Sachen raussuchen.
Die Texte sind ja verlinkt, also man kann direkt den Text anklicken,
den wir gelesen haben und kommt dann unten auf die Steady-Seite,
in der man unsere Besprechung findet.
Wunderbar, dann sehen wir uns im Salon. Bis gleich.
Bis gleich.